vor fünf Jahren habe ich mir in den Kopf
gesetzt dass ich einen Resthof kaufen
möchte und nach dieser ewig langen Suche
ist mein größter Traum jetzt endlich
Realität geworden vor drei Tagen sind
wir eingezogen und ehrlich gesagt fühlt
sich das alles immer noch nicht wirklich
real an dieser Garten ist so unfassbar
schön heute Nacht konnte ich einfach
nicht mehr weiterschlafen weil ich so
viele Ideen und Träume im Kopf habe was
wir aus diesem Haus machen können und
aus dem Garten machen können dass ich
einfach aufgestanden bin um ein bisschen
an den Wänden rum zu spachteln am
liebsten würde ich alles auf einmal
machen und ich glaube was wir jetzt als
erstes lernen müssen ist dass das nicht
geht so ein Projekt nach dem anderen und
wir werden natürlich alles hier mit euch
teilen also folgt uns gerne wenn ihr bei
unserem Hof Abenteuer mit dabei sein
wollt